j'ai en moi des gosses je voulais savoir
par rapport à la manifestation de samedi
c'est une rom remobilisation des déchets
les jeunes quelles sont les
revendications encore une fois un 2
propose ce samedi
alors cet appel qui est elle qui est à
l'origine est un appel à l'échelle
nationale c'était de faire en sorte que
les jets les jo ne se reconcentre autour
de leur valeur historique et des trois
revendications pour lesquelles ont été
descendus dans la rue le 17 novembre qui
permettaient à la fois de faire revenir
des gilet jaune qui par la répression ne
sais tu descendais plus dans la rue et
d'essayer des agglomérés l'ensemble les
colères autre que gilet jaune à ce
pouvoir venir dans la rue et et crier
leur colère
donc j'ai appelé l'ensemble des deux ce
qui actionne aujourd'hui en france a
récupéré les péages à récupérer les
ronds-points et les différents centres
villes aujourd'hui pour tout en france
ce samedi 12 septembre pour pouvoir
crier notre colère bien sûr le plus
pacifiquement possible au niveau de la
mobilisation vous attendez à une grosse
mobilisation sur paris les chaînes s si
j'étais devant je pourrais te dire oui
il va y avoir du monde je sais pas j'ai
pas les données j'ai quelques
statistiques peuvent remonter pour
l'instant en tout cas
l'appel a été bien reçu les jets les
jeunes sont contents et pour preuve
c'est que même d'autres corporations qui
sont en colère comme les discothèques en
colère où vous les vtc ont rejoint
l'appel du 12 septembre donc déjà
premier pari je pense déjà réussi à voir
votre réaction concernant
un tweet que vous avez fait il ya
quelques temps par rapport à la police
par rapport aux camps de concentration
gérald darmanin annoncé qu'il allait
déposer plainte votre réaction là dessus
je suis super peur je suis en panique
totale
je veux dire une plainte contre un deuil
perdu je prends toutes les plantes du
monde n'y a pas de souci maintenant je
suis apprécié que c'est pas un tweet
c'était une réponse à un tweet dollars
que synergie officiers a mis en place je
tiens à préciser que je n'insulte pas
l'ensemble de la police j'insulte ceux
qui sont derrière ce compte twitter
parce que eux quand ils se permettent de
me traiter de fond de cuve
il ya moins d'une semaine dans
différents commentaires ne me faire
traiter de cyclope j'ai jamais vu un
quelconque ministre ou même syndicat a
porté plainte au souffle puisque et de
l'ensemble des menaces que je peux
recevoir au sein de la manif
quand vous avez les mecs de la brave qui
me menace de me crever le deuxième oeil
et j'ai des vidéos ou quand je me fais
insulter de connard voyez ça va j'ai pas
l'impression que monsieur darmanin
trépigne sur ses pieds puis voilà
quelque part c'est du corporatisme
c'est normal qu'ils défendent ces
policiers c'est dommage c'est normal
qu'ils défendent ces petites demoiselles
d'honneur qui était présente
armés jusqu'aux dents autour de son
mariage elle leur doit bien ça quand
même hein c'est normal donc dans
l'absolu ça me dérange pas plus
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire me prendre
ce que j'ai plus me prendre plus qu ils
m'ont enlevé aujourd'hui dans ma vie
amusez vous en même temps vous êtes en
train de gâcher l'argent du contribuable
pour des petits des injures ce que
j'appelle les embrouilles de sucettes et
de vol de bonbons à la récré je pense
qu'il serait peut-être plus intéressant
de mettre dans l'argent à améliorer
aujourd'hui votre police est de faire en
sorte de virer tous ces personnes qui
mettent justement à mal l'image de la
police justement pas juste par rapport à
cette réponse de truites justement pour
ce peut-être qu'ils n'ont pas qu'ils ne
comprennent pas forcément à ce que ça
voulait dire par concentration vous avez
parlé c'était quoi en fait nettement les
camps de concentration c'est ce que
c'est un endroit au nord-est de paris où
sont parqués lee gilet jaune pendant les
manifestations sur des arrestations
arbitraires donc la référence nazis
c'est par rapport à tous les propos
racistes qu'on peut entendre de la part
de la police
et de rajouter camps de concentration
pour alerter les médias qu aujourd'hui
il ya un camp où on parque les gilet
jaune pour leur priver de la liberté le
samedi
alors faudrait peut-être plus offusqué
de ça aujourd'hui dans un pays comme la
france qui se veut démocratique de
l'idée de parcs et des gens parce que
démocratiquement ils ont le droit
inaliénable de pouvoir manifeste
c'est que de s'offusquer sur un propos
que les uns et les autres peuvent tenir
parce qu'ils m'ont autant insulter que
je les insultes merci à toi